euh deuxième grand thème d'actualité
pour ce sens public l'engrenage de la
violence en Israël et en Palestine
depuis jeudi dernier la politique
répressive de Netanyahou et les
attentats Palestiniens se répandent
peut-on encore éviter une nouvelle
Intifada pendant des battre le point sur
l'enchaînement des faits avec Mathias
quelle est la Palestine de nouveau face
au risque d'embrasement ce vendredi
c'est un Palestinien de 21 ans qui est
passé à l'acte devant une synagogue dans
l'est de Jérusalem une attaque à l'arme
à feu faisant cette victime mortelle il
s'agit de l'une des attaques terroristes
les plus odieuses que nous ayons connu
ces dernières années et d'une
augmentation significative du degré de
terreur à Gaza cette attaque est
célébrée si elle n'est juste alors pas
revendiquée le Hamas première force
politique palestinienne parle de
vengeance l'attaque d'aujourd'hui à
Jérusalem est une réaction normale au
crime de l'occupation contre notre
peuple palestinien dans le dernier en
date a eu lieu dans la ville de Jenny ou
10 personnes ont été tués dont une femme
âgée le lendemain samedi un jeune
Palestinien de 13 ans ouvre le feu non
loin de la vieille ville de Jérusalem la
saillant fait de blessés graves avant
d'être neutralisé dans la foulée de
cette deuxième attaque le Premier
ministre conservateur israélien Benyamin
Netanyahou annonce plus de 40 et exprime
sa volonté d'aller plus loin
notre réponse sera forte rapide et
précise quiconque essaie de nous blesser
nous
répliqueronsiennes détruisaient les
maisons de Palestiniens coupable de
meurtre avec un préavis aux familles et
une possibilité de faire appel suite aux
attaques de ce week-end la procédure a
été accélérée et les maisons des
assaillants déjà scellées
deux grandes questions dans ce débat
peut-on éviter une nouvelle Intifada et
la démocratie israélienne est-elle en
danger je vous présente mes invités
Nissan Perelman bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes docteur en temps sociologie
politique ingénieur d'études au CNRS
Sami Cohen bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
directeur de recherche et mérite au
Centre d'études et de recherche
internationale
deux Sciences Po et auteur de ce livre
israélien démocratie fragile aux
éditions Fayard à minifereb bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi chercheuse au
Centre d'études de sécurité et
coordinatrice du laboratoire de
recherche sur la défense de l'Institut
français des relations internationales
Mathieu croissanto évidemment est resté
à mes côtés est-ce que vous liés un peu
vous poser la même question et je vais
commencer avec vous ça m'y connais
est-ce que vous vouliez les violences de
ces derniers jours au retour au pouvoir
de Benyamin Netanyahou et de ses alliés
d'extrême droite non clairement non les
les retours le retour des violences
datent en fait à peu près de du mois de
mars 2022 donc en avant les élections à
cette époque là il y a eu une série
d'attentats dans des villes israéliennes
tel à vivre un bercheva dont elle a add
et et en fait pour répondre à cette à
cette série d'attaques le gouvernement a
bien réalisé que des tas de régions si
Jordanie était avaient été délaissé du
point de vue de la sécurité
et télé région dans lesquelles même
l'Autorité palestinienne n'avait pas
beaucoup de contrôle donc en fait ils
ont ils sont revenus en force avec des
opérations qui consiste à aller arrêter
des gens aller prévenir des attentats en
fait à focaliser l'attention des groupes
armés sur ces opérations et les empêcher
de s'organiser et de conduire des
opérations terroristes en Israël
bon donc ça ça a mené
à des à des résultats pour l'instant
assez assez contestable parce que en
fait il y a eu pratiquement 150
palestiniens qui ont été tués dans ces
opérations et on pensait que ces
opérations mais très fin au terrorisme
mais voilà patatra vendredi soir il y a
un acte de terrorisme très important
dramatique qui a causé la mort de de
cette pauvre juive qui sortait de
destinagoc
je reviens vers vous tout à l'heure mais
Nissan berelman si on prend la séquence
de ces de ces derniers jours c'est à
dire jeudi à ce raid israélien dans le
camp de Jenny la réaction
parfois on est un peu binaire dans dans
notre analyse donc ce qu'il faut je m'en
complexifier l'analyse la réaction du
lendemain cette attentat contre la
synagogue est-ce que vous vous le liés
alors tout d'abord moi je vais rappeler
que l'année 2022 était l'année la plus
Mortière depuis la seconde indie Fada
c'est-à-dire plus de 200 palestiniens
tués partout en 6 jours d'amis un
jérusalemet et là au mois de janvier
plus de 1 Palestiniens par jour et tu es
en 6 Jordanie également on voit que un
génie il y a une opération qui se
termine par 10 Palestiniens qui sont
tués bien sûr il y a aussi des enfants
qui sont dans le jeu et là on voit
un élément qu'il faut pas ignorer
première attentat commis par un jeune
Palestinien de 21 ans deuxième attentat
par un jeune Palestinien de 13 ans et ça
c'est extrêmement important parce qu'on
se demande comment un enfant de 13 ans
et pourquoi il veut s'attaquer à des
Juifs et là on comprend qu'il faut tout
de suite bien sûr on condamne très vite
les attaques et c'est très important de
le condamner mais aussi c'est important
de poser les bonnes questions qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui se passe quand un
enfant de 13 ans sort de sa maison avec
un arme pour attaquer à des Israéliens
elle a bien sûr il faut poser les bonnes
questions par rapport à la cupcation qui
serait elle-même depuis 67 mais aussi à
la violence extrême que bah qui
caractérise ce dernier mois mais est-ce
qu'on est voilà justement est-ce qu'on
est dans une phase particulière là
depuis je reviens à la question cette
semaine mais même depuis le retour au
pouvoir de manière minette tanyahou
c'était fin décembre
je dirais que oui parce que là il y a
bengir aussi au pouvoir avec Netanyahu
et bengwir non seulement lui il parle il
dit il faut qu'on s'attaque de manière
très agressive etc mais aussi les
soldats qui comprennent que pouvoir il y
a Itamar Beng véritable a été élu par
20% des soldats un soldat sur 5 a voté
pour etama Ben des ministres de la
sécurité nationale exactement
un chapitre entier dans dans quelques
minutes on va essayer parce que je suis
sûr qu'il y a une bonne partie du public
français qui ne le connaît pas forcément
on va bien détailler son son parcours
est-ce que représente sa présence au
sein d'un d'un gouvernement
améli Ferré même question comment vous
analysez la la séquence depuis un mois
et voilà le on se demande toujours et
d'ailleurs dans les réactions
internationales il y a aussi cette
question qui qui a intérêt à souffler
sur les braises
je pense que effectivement le la
question de la chronologie elle revient
à chaque nouvelle flambée de violence à
chaque embrasement et pour moi c'est
important de replacer justement le
conflit dans une chronologie qui est
longue parce que on voit en fait il y a
eu mai 2021 il y a eu août 2022 il y a
eu les attentats
a rappelé et il faut vraiment concevoir
le conflit israélo-palestinien comme un
conflit qui est en cours qui alterne
entre les phases justement plus de haute
intensité et de basse intensité mais qui
est en cours et donc finalement on
assiste aujourd'hui à effectivement une
flambée de violence mais qui doit être
comprise dans le fait que le conflit
perdure et tant qu'il y a pas de
solutions politiques qui est posée pour
ce conflit là il y aura pas de règlement
aujourd'hui du conflit et par ailleurs
sur la question de la chronologie il
faut aussi à mon sens éviter le piège de
rentrer dans il y a eu un attentat et
donc du coup il y a eu un autre accord
c'était une analyse un peu binaire mais
très souvent comme si en fait il y avait
que comme si le cycle de représailles
légitimait la violence alors qu'en fait
chaque épisode de violence devrait être
illégitime et illégal puisque
normalement on arrive quand il y a des
différends dans des sociétés à trouver
des solutions pacifiques via la
politique et pas par la force militaire
mais par contre comme la rappeler à
Nissan très justement le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que on a un
gouvernement qui ne voit que le l'option
militaire comme la seule option
permettant de de régler le problème
palestinien et donc on a eu Donald Trump
qui a essayé en son temps de donner une
solution économique en disant voilà si
on fait le Diox de Century et qu'on
donne de l'argent au Palestiniens on va
pouvoir avoir une paix plus ou moins
stable et ça ne n'a pas fonctionné on a
eu la paix politique avec
Oslo qui aussi n'a pas fonctionné et
donc aujourd'hui ce qui me semble
préoccupant c'est justement cette
absence de de d'espoir ça m'y connais
est-ce qu'il y a encore des des
liens des lieux de de discussions de
négociation entre Palestiniens et
Israéliens dans le contexte actuel avec
un Benyamine étaiaou et ses alliés
d'extrême droite au pouvoir et côté
palestinien et voilà un pouvoir assez
fragilisé assez éclaté non au niveau
des dirigeants en fait il y a pas
il y a une coopération sécuritaire qui a
été arrêté par Mahmoud Abbas à la suite
de l'attaque contre
un appartement dans lequel se trouvait
des combattants du Djihad islamique qui
a fait à peu près 7 ou 8 morts en fait
d'un seul coup
non il y a pas grand canaux de de
discussions et même même informel ou
même secret écoutez ce secret je ne sais
pas
puisqu'elles sont secrètes par
définition de les connaît pas j'imagine
qu'il y a toujours des des
direct entre le shabbat le service de
sécurité israélien et les services
sécurité palestiniens ils sont ils sont
en contact sur le terrain ils vivent
pratiquement ensemble bon mais au-delà
les contacts politiques qui sont les
plus importants quand même au fond on
voit pas grand chose les seuls contacts
qu'il faut le rappeler les seuls
contacts on disait pas destinien qui
sont des contacts
au bas de la société israélienne ce sont
les mouvements de paix ce sont des
organisations de de de de notamment les
familles endeuillées israéliennes et
palestinienne mais qui œuvrent ensemble
qui s'activent en son pour essayer de
faire comprendre que l'autre n'est pas
n'est pas le démon n'est et quelqu'un
avec qui on peut parler que cette
situation est insupportable pour les
deux parties pour essayer de de se
parler des problèmes des plus des plus
sensibles plus difficiles les Israéliens
veulent parler de la Nakba ou pourront
parler d'un Alba c'est
en fait en arabe c'est la catastrophe ce
que les Palestiniens définissent comme
pour les Israéliens l'indépendance en
1948 pour Israël c'est une victoire pour
les Palestiniens c'est la marque bas et
donc ces mouvements de paix veulent se
parler les palais des Palestiniens sont
prêts à parler de la Shoah notamment
mais mais que pèse-t-il dans l'opinion
des deux des deux côtés voilà c'est on y
viendra évidemment Matthieu vous disiez
je voulais rebondir sur ce que vous
disiez vous disiez tout à l'heure
fallait pas d'une certaine façon sur
interprétée la chronologie des
événements et d'une certaine manière
est-ce qu'il faut peut-être pas sur
interpréter les caractères politiques
alors je prends plein de guillemets pour
dire ça j'ai cru lire mais peut-être
vous allez me corriger que on
s'interrogeait aussi de savoir si parmi
ces terroristes parmi ces attentats
c'était pas l'oeuvre de loup solitaire
ou de gens qui pouvaient avoir des
histoires personnelles de vengeance je
pense à l'auteur de de l'attentat
navigakov qui lui avait perdu son
grand-père assassiné par un colon 4 ans
est-ce qu'on est passé dans une dans une
sorte de vente d'État au-delà évidemment
de la question politique qui reste
prégnante entre les Palestiniens et
Israéliens pour moi c'est une excellente
question et c'est sûr que le thème de la
vengeance de la vendetta est présent
dans le discours politique israélien et
présent aussi dans les représentations
du conflit le problème c'est que
pourquoi en fait on a interdit la
vengeance privée au sein des sociétés
c'est que justement les individus en
fait se saisissent eux-mêmes de la
question de la justice et donc
s'autorise à utiliser la violence pour
mener
cette justice là où les États ne sont
plus capables de les faire et moi ce qui
me semble très inquiétant dans la
situation politique aujourd'hui c'est
que des deux côtés on a un effondrement
en fait de l'état du côté de l'Autorité
palestinienne qui est complètement
délicaissant avec mahmouda base qui
n'apparaît pas comme capable de protéger
les Palestiniens dans leur vie de tous
les jours et de l'autre côté on a la
démocratie israélienne qui elle aussi
s'effondre avec la cour suprême qui
était là pour protéger en fait aussi les
Palestiniens notamment en imposant des
contraintes à l'armée et en protégeant
leurs droits les plus alimentaires qui
est aussi en train de s'effondrer et
donc ce qu'on voit et d'ailleurs on l'a
vu dans les attentats quand il y a des
personnes qui utilisent leur propre
armes pour neutraliser les terroristes
donc heureusement qu'ils ont neutralisé
ces personnes mais on peut quand même
s'interroger sur le fait qu'il y a de
plus en plus d'armes qui circulent sur
les violences interethniques aussi qu'on
a vu lors des précédents conflits entre
Palestiniens d'Israël et israéliens et
moi je pense que c'est ça qui est très
inquiétant c'est que si on rentre dans
ces logiques de vendetta personnel en
fait on ajoute de la violence à la
violence et on permet pas donc un
règlement de ce conflit une nouvelle
Intifada est-elle inévitable on va
essayer de répondre à cette question et
je vous propose d'abord ce sondage
publié dans le quotidien israélien
arrête la réponse est et oui pour 61%
des Palestiniens et pour 65% des Juifs
israéliens
ce sondage il a été publié avant la
séquence dont on parle dans dans notre
débat c'est dire avant je dis dernier
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à cette
question sur la une éventuelle troisième
institut Fada tout d'abord moi je suis
beaucoup moins optimiste malheureusement
que Samy Cohen parce que la paix on est
brossé chaleur mais c'est aussi bonjour
et je sais que dans la société
israélienne on utilise maintenant le mot
Shalom uniquement pour dire bonjour et
on parle plus de la paix donc on parle
de un mouvement interoccupation mais
est-ce que le Mouvement de la Paix
existe malheureusement on ne voit très
rarement donc je pense qu'il y a quand
même surtout après mai 2021 et donc
après ces élections où il y a un
désespoir et bien sûr depuis l'échec des
accords d'Oslo puis deuxième Intifada
puis les deux opérations très violentes
à Gaza en 2008 et 2014 on va vraiment un
déclin de l'espoir et on se demande plus
est-ce qu'il y a une solution mais
comment on fait perdurer à la situation
qui est assez calme mais qui ne parvient
à aucune vraie solution de la situation
quand on parle d'intifada c'est quoi ça
mouvement populaire profond de
soulèvement des Palestiniens notamment
des jeunes donc ça rejoint peut-être un
peu ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure là
encore j'essaye de pas être trop
simpliste mais on a deux auteurs
d'attentats qui sont qui sont
particulièrement jeunes est-ce que c'est
un élément supplémentaire pour dire que
Fada est malheureusement possible
malheureusement oui parce que voilà on
voit le jaune qui a 21 ans donc si on
calcule très vite on voit que c'était
pendant la deuxième Intifada qu'il a été
né puis à notre jeune de 13 ans alors il
est né en 2010 aussi on une période très
violente et donc les deux les jeunes
Palestiniens aujourd'hui sont
complètement
c'est pire que les Israéliens parce
qu'ils sont vraiment dans le désespoir
et face à la violence à la fois de
l'État israélien mais aussi des colons
qui qui sont de plus en plus présentes
ont si Jordanie intervenir parce que
c'est presque impossible de répondre à
la question que je pose c'est ça c'est
c'est trop imprévisible
il faut se rappeler qu'il y en a eu deux
toutes les deux ont éclaté de manière
imprévisible donc c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui de dire qu'elle va éclater
ou qu'elle va pas éclater on ne sait pas
lorsque béni est allé sur le monde du
temple pour faire sa provocation ça
c'était le 3 janvier c'était à peu près
3 janvier de mémoire 8 jours à peu près
tout le monde ah voilà ça va provoquer
une flambée de violence et les
Palestiniens ça n'a rien provoqué du
tout bizarrement bon voilà les les la
première a été provoqué à la suite d'un
accident de camion donc il y a tout à
fait imprévisible la deuxième à la suite
la visite de Sharon sur le monde du
temple la 3e tout le monde en parle mais
ça peut ne pas arriver on n'en sais rien
il faut dire alors la visite je pense
qu'on fait allusion à la même moi c'est
je vous propose un extrait du donc de ce
déplacement du nouveau ministre
israélien de la sécurité intérieure dont
on parlait tout à l'heure il t'a
marbenvir qui alors on est alors ce
qu'on va vous montrer c'est le 3 janvier
donc il vient le gouvernement Netanyahou
c'est 29 décembre donc c'est quasiment
un de ses premiers gestes officiels et
il va effectivement sur le monde du
temple qu'on appelle aussi l'esplanade
des Mosquées regardez ce qu'il dit
le gouvernement israélien ne se
soumettra pas à une organisation
d'assassins à une organisation
terroriste méprisable le monde du temple
et le lieu le plus important pour le
peuple d'Israël le monde du temple est
ouvert à tous musulman et chrétiens
viennent ici et oui les Juifs aussi dans
un gouvernement dont je suis membre il
n'y aura pas de racisme ni de
discrimination et les Juifs iront sur le
monde du temple donc clarifions cela
pour le Hamas nous ne nous inclinons pas
que ça veut dire quoi précisément cette
déclaration alors il y a le côté
provocateur on la référence achat on en
a bien compris tout ça mais qu'est-ce
qu'il y a derrière mais en fait il y a
cette question de du statut en fait de
laisser un des mosquées parce que pour
les Palestiniens donc c'est un
territoire qui est géré par la Jordanie
en fait donc qui n'est pas sous contrôle
d'Israël et pour les païciens c'est
vraiment un symbole à la fois de de
l'iode d'identité palestinienne il faut
savoir que le tombeau donc de yasserafat
et orienté vers le vers la mosquée et
par ailleurs c'est aussi un des symboles
qui permet d'unifier le monde arabe et
notamment le monde musulman à la cause
palestinienne et de l'autre côté pour
les Juifs c'est donc le lieu le plus
sacré puisque donc il y a la fondation
du temple et il y a chez une frange de
la partie religieuse donc orthodoxe des
Juifs qui habitent à Jérusalem la
volonté de reconstruire en fait le
temple et donc ce qui impliquerait de
détruire la mosquée et donc il y a une
forme de de
peur en fait des deux côtés à la fois du
côté israélien donc justement de
défendre le mur de lamentations et de
défendre l'accès et la souveraineté en
fait d'Israël sur Jérusalem qui est la
capitale éternelle et indivisible de
l'État d'Israël et qui est évidemment
crucial dans l'identité israélienne mais
il y a également cette peur chez les
Palestiniens de perdre ce symbole et
donc vraiment c'est un lieu qui
géographiquement et qui qui incarne de
cette tension
identitaire qui existe entre les deux
peuples c'est qui Benji il faut rappeler
son parcours politique parce que encore
une fois bon tout le monde ne le connaît
pas ici c'est très important tout
d'abord je vais dire qu'il est monté sur
l'Esplan de
mosquée sans l'autorisation de
Netanyahoo il a parlé avec lui
netanyawadi attendez un tout petit peu
et il a il a pas fait et c'était à 7h du
matin donc c'était pas en plein milieu
de la journée mais benguire je vais vous
dire comment la société israélienne le
voit la première fois en 95 on voit le
jeune benvir avec l'emblème de de la
voiture de Rabine et
sa carabine et on dit on a touché sa
voiture on est arrivé à sa voiture on va
arriver à la personne on va arriver ce
qui sera assassiné quelques jours plus
quelques jours plus tard alors ça c'est
la première fois qu'on va bénir c'était
c'est passé vraiment dans les infos en
Israël bengwir a 17 ans il faisait
[Musique]
très très radical qui s'appelle car de
merkana et l'armée vous savez que le
service militaire et obligatoire en
Israël l'armée n'a pas accepté benvir il
n'a pas autorisé à son service militaire
de peur qu'il soit trop radical dans
l'armée donc mouvement de mémoire a été
classé organisation théorique par l'État
d'Israël lui-même à l'époque c'est ça
en 2007 bengir lui-même et condamné de
soutien d'une organisation terroriste
donc
vous voyez très bien son parcours si en
2013 qu'un Bennett arrive au Parlement
on dit ah mais Naftal et Bennett il est
très radical et en 2021 il est premier
ministre qui est considéré considéré
modéré regardez ce qui se passe
maintenant avec bengirl bengiron 95 il
faisait partie des personnes qui
disaient qu'il fallait tuer il tracabine
il avait dans son salon le portrait de
bar Goldstein c'était un terroriste juif
qui a tué presque 30 musulmans dans un
mosquée en 94 et voilà aujourd'hui il
est le ministre de la Sécurité Nationale
qu'est-ce que ça dit de la société
israélienne aujourd'hui la présence de
bengwi au gouvernement et à ce poste ben
je dirais que rien de bon rien de bon
parce que au fond qu'est-ce qui a permis
à benvir de d'être député d'abord c'est
netanyan qui a permis l'Italien qui
voulait un soutien des parties de droite
qui savaient très bien qui ne passerait
pas sans nos soutien des électeurs de la
droite et donc il a encouragé ce mot
triche le chef du partitionniste
religieux et benguire de s'allier pour
récupérer les voies de de benvir afin
qu'elle ne soit pas perdue là il a le
vent tabou parce qu'il y avait un tabou
dans les années 80-984 il me semble ou
86 84 la cnesset avait voté
l'interdiction du parti de Robben
merkana de siéger à l'acnécette donc ce
parti était interdit Benyamin netanyon à
lever le tabou a permis aucun anis de
revenir à la cnsset ensuite ce qui s'est
passé c'est que il faut pas oublier il y
a eu l'échec quand même de ce cours
période où il y a eu un ministre un
cabinet un gouvernement mené par des
gens relativement modérés mais dans
lequel il y avait Nathalie Bennett qui
est lui aussi stationnée de religieux et
qui n'a pas réussi à
sauvegarder la coalition ces électeurs
sont allés renforcés le partitionniste
religieux donc on a en fait toute une
série de une succession de facteurs pas
un seul qui a permis à bénir et à
smotrich de représenter en fait d'être
14 députés sur dans une majorité qui
compte 62 députés c'est quand même
énorme mais quand même beaucoup
effectivement alors il y a j'entends ce
que vous dites c'est passionnant il y a
une partie de on va dire de stratégie
politique de Benyamine Netanyahou
cynisme politique on peut remplir ce
terme-là mais il fait il y a aussi la
société enfin la droitisation de la
société israélienne c'est aussi bien sûr
bien sûr il y a deux éléments
effectivement il y a aussi les intérêts
objectifs en fait qu'à Nathan Yahoo
affaire alliance avec la liste sionisme
religieux puisque cette réforme
judiciaire qui est portée par ces
ministres va en fait lever certains des
obstacles qui s'étaient que nathana
rencontré puisqu'il est mis en affaires
quand même dans trois affaires de
corruption enfin mis en examen pardon et
l'autre point c'est aussi la
responsabilité du liquide justement
cette droitisation de la société parce
que vous avez depuis des années un
discours qui est extrêmement raciste qui
s'est banalisé en fait contre les
Palestiniens et je trouve que le point
sur les électeurs qui effectivement qui
est quelqu'un qui était pour la
colonisation mais qui aussi venait de la
high-tech et qui était quand même assez
vu comme voilà partisan d'un libéralisme
économique au moins ces personnels se
sont reportés vers benvy parce que
benvir apparaît comme la personne qui va
vraiment le défendre l'intérêt des
colons à l'intérieur d'Israël et ça ça
passe par
la destruction en fait de l'État de
droit et de la démocratie et aujourd'hui
si vous regardez en fait l'état Israël
au niveau démographique évidemment cette
jeunesse qui est religieuse cette
jeunesse des colonies et ben elle elle
est beaucoup plus attirée par un
discours de benvir qui est beaucoup plus
volontariste qui est beaucoup plus
populiste aussi donc qui qui présente
des solutions de manière extrêmement
caricaturale à un conflit qui est très
compliqué comme on le sait et pour et la
gauche en face elle est moins importante
au niveau démographique et aussi elle a
un discours qui est beaucoup moins Audi
parce que beaucoup plus complexe
que je vais vous proposer parce que moi
je suis d'une génération on a connu des
premiers ministres travaillistes des
voix qui comptaient ils sont où
aujourd'hui les travailler et
qu'ils ont une part de responsabilités
ce qu'a dit la chef du Parti travail
après les attentats on dirait vraiment
on a un tweet parce que elle a twitté ça
de
toute personne de la droite elle a dit
il faut combattre contre ce terror de
manière très agressive et de manière
très forte elle dit avec une main ferme
donc c'est ça qu'elle dit tout de suite
après et après il y a un parlementaire
de mérite qui lui dit mais écoutez très
bien mais est-ce que vous pouvez aussi
parler de pourquoi ce terror est parlé
aussi de l'occupation c'est-à-dire
aujourd'hui bah là pendant longtemps
aussi le parti travailler ça changeait
le nom pour apparaître un peu plus
attirant ça s'appelait le cancioniste
mais le parti travailliste avec cette
idéologie de la gauche n'existe vraiment
plus on peut l'assimiler très bien avec
qui est châtie des Carole avant tout les
parties du centre ici et si je peux
juste ajouter un point sur ça je trouve
que le renommer donc Avoda pour le
cancuniste c'est très intéressant parce
que le problème c'est que la gauche
s'est fait enfermer en fait dans
l'alternative qui a été posée par Nadia
new c'est-à-dire soit vous êtes pro
sionisme polycoon donc sa version du
sionisme soit vous êtes contre et donc
vous êtes contre l'État d'Israël et donc
vous êtes un traître et en fait la
gauche elle s'est laissée enfermer dans
ça donc maintenant il y a cette sorte de
de culpabilité qu'à la gauche qui doit
toujours montrer de patte blanche
vis-à-vis du sionisme et qui se fait
régulièrement justement taxer de
traîtrise par les députés de droite et
du coup vous avez un effondrement total
parce que la gauche n'a pas un discours
contre l'occupation en réalité alors je
reviens sur la question de la
droitisation de la société et peut-être
le poids des Juifs orthodoxes ça
migraine parce que c'est aussi un poids
économique il y a des lignes de bus il y
a une compagnie aérienne enfin il faut
peut-être aussi un peu détailler ça ce
que ce que pèse ce même économiquement
ce courant de
politique pour en religieux en Israël
les Ultra autodores aujourd'hui
représentent à peu près 12% de
l'électorat israélien
lorsque l'État d'Israël a été créé nous
représentait que 4 %. donc on voit bien
compte tenu de leur taux de natalité la
progression démographique le Bureau
central des statistiques israéliens à
calculer qu'en 2060 si la
la courbe démographique continuait à
l'identique les
ultras orthodoxes en 2060 représenterait
à peu près 30% de la population
israélienne ce qui est énorme c'est à
dire qu'il pourrait faire et défaire les
gouvernements comme il l'entende bon
ceux qui représentent d'abord un poids
extrêmement important concernant toutes
les lois qui touchent à la famille le
mariage le divorce l'identité juive
grosse route
l'alimentation dans les cantines
publiques et là ils en ont ils ont à
chaque fois qu'ils le peuvent ils
essaient de mon de monnailler leur
soutien le soutien politique on échange
d'un soutien financier pour que leur
école religieuses soient financées en
fait elles sont financées par qui par
par le public qui n'est pas religieux et
avec aussi des menaces de boycott sur
certaines
marques si elle joue pas forcément le
jeu enfin parce que quand on pèse 12% de
l'opinion on a un poids économique j'y
reviens oui un point économique mais le
poids politique est beaucoup plus
important je vous donne un exemple au
moment où Robin était premier ministre
dans les années 70 ils avaient fait
chuter le gouvernement Rabine parce que
Rabby n'avait autorisé
que les avions achetés les avions de
chasse acheter aux États-Unis puisse
atterrir en Israël un shabbat et là ils
ont dit si atterrissent un shabbat nous
démissionnons ils ont démissionné le
gouvernement et le gouvernement rabbin
est tombé à cause de ça donc le repas
politique et vraiment est décisive ils
peuvent faire des faire certains
gouvernements et là je dirais
personnellement je suis franchement
assez pessimiste contenu de
l'accroissement du poids démographique
des religieux les religieux
orthodoxes et 12%, les religieux
sillonnistes religieux qui représentent
des nationalistes certains sont très
proches des ultra autodocs certains sont
plus éloignés mais c'est des
ultrasnationalistes quand même
l'ensemble ils forment pour l'instant un
quart de la population israélienne bon
franchement compte tenu des la courbe
démographique je ne suis pas très
optimiste est-ce que on va on ouvre un
peu on en parle déjà dans ce débat mais
on va se centrer un peu plus sur la
question de la de la fragilité de la
démocratie israélienne ou de la dérive
de la démocratie sienne
est-ce que ça fait peur économiquement
je reste sur cet angle là à des
investisseurs ou à des entreprises qui
qui étaient déjà installées on parlait
Israël c'est un pays en terme de tech de
qui est souvent très avancé dans
beaucoup de domaines ça match pas tout à
fait bien avec les Juifs orthodoxes
parce que je suis en train de dire mais
c'est un point très important parce que
il y a quelques jours en grande
entreprise des d'arrêter qui seraient
qui s'appelle papaya a décidé de retirer
ses fonds d'Israël parce que il y a la
réforme judiciaire peut-être on aura
pour tenter d'en parler et du coup de
les fablissement de la démocratie
israélienne et ça pour moi c'est un
point majeur parce que bon on voit les
manifestations qui sont aussi très
intéressantes mais il y avait aussi des
manifestations des employés de high-tech
et on voit aussi des investisseurs qui
commencent à avoir de plus en plus peur
et de s'inquiéter par rapport à la
situation politique en Israël et ça je
pense que
ça va servir comme tournant dans cette
réforme judiciaire qui est dans cette
réforme musicale pourquoi était le
critiquée critiquable comme judiciaire
et planifiée par notamment un
parlementaire de liquide y arrive les
vignes depuis 20 ans et là c'est le
moment où le gouvernement est très à
droite et très fort parce qu'il y a un
coalition de 64 par les menteurs il veut
faire passer une réforme et entre les
éléments il y a par exemple le la
modification très radicale du comité qui
nomme les juges de manière qui est
vraiment tout le temps on ne majorité
pour le gouvernement pour le
gouvernement puisse nommer très
facilement des jeux au moins
d'indépendance judiciaire si vous
comprend bien c'est ça le plus important
c'est que en Israël et ça on oublie de
mentionner à chaque fois il n'y a aucun
mécanisme qui permet là séparation de
pouvoir pourquoi parce que il y a le
pouvoir
exécutif qui a une coalition majorité
dans le Parlement du coup le pouvoir
législatif et le pouvoir judiciaire a
une seule un seul pouvoir par rapport au
gouvernement et c'est le fait que en 92
il y a la loi fondamentale en Israël il
y a pas de Constitution il y a une voix
fondamentale qui est à vrai dire on loi
simple mais on doit fondamental sur la
dignité de l'homme qui permet jusqu'à
maintenant la Cour suprême d'annuler des
lois qui sont contre les bah du coup les
les droits de l'homme je rappelle qu'il
y a juste 20 lois qui ont été annulées
depuis 92 est-ce qu'ils veulent faire
dans cette réforme c'est tout simplement
annuler cette possibilité d'accord donc
là là on est en train d'identifier un
risque pour la démocratie is moyenne qui
est très clair
Amélie ferrée vous parliez tout à
l'heure de de en réponse à une question
de Mathieu sur le risque finalement dans
les deux camps que chacun cherche à se
la vendetta à se faire justice par
soi-même mais mais ça va même dans
l'orgue vous parlez du panda dans
l'organisation dans certains quartiers
est-ce que il y a certaines zones en
Israël ou finalement on se fait justice
soi-même quoi dans les colonies par
exemple puisque en fait le problème
c'est que toutes les colonies qui sont
donc situées en si Jordanie en fait
Israël n'a pas juridiquement
souveraineté sur ces territoires là donc
en fait les Palestiniens qui vivent à
proximité des colonies eux sont soumis à
l'armée israélienne qui a deux fait un
régime d'occupation avec une justice
militaire qui s'applique et par contre
les colons eux ne peuvent pas être
traduits en justice devant des cours
israéliennes puisque ces territoires ne
font pas partie d'Israël
la police
ça crée une forme de milicisation de
ces territoires là avec des personnes
qui sont prêtes effectivement à se faire
justice elle-même et qui est de toutes
les manières ont des armes à disposition
et justement enfin je reviens sur la
réforme judiciaire et sur ce que vous
avez dit sur la tech en fait à
l'intérieur de la société israélienne je
le mentionne ce que c'est quand même
intéressant il y a une série télé qui
est sortie qui a eu pas mal de bruit qui
faisait l'hypothèse en fait d'une
scission à l'intérieur d'Israël entre un
pays qui est un pays religieux et un
pays laïc ça s'appelle autonomie donc
avec une autonomie sur Tel Aviv qui
serait la bulle des laïcs et le reste
des des personnes religieuses et c'est
vraiment ça en fait aujourd'hui le
problème c'est qu'on a une forme
d'archipelisation vous avez donc à
l'intérieur d'Israël 20% de Palestiniens
d'Israël donc des personnes qui sont des
Palestiniens qui sont restés en Israël
vous avez possiblement donc enfin
aujourd'hui 12% mais peut-être plus de
religieux et vous avez les laïcs et en
fait ce sont des communautés qui très
antagoniste et donc le problème c'est
comment vous faites quand vous êtes un
état qui repose sur la notion quand même
de bien public et d'égalité devant la
loi pour tenir face à ces différents
mouvements contradictoires alors là on y
est en train d'identifier sa mikoen des
faiblesses de la démocratie israélienne
il y avait construit votre livre c'est
même son le titre une démocratie fragile
j'ai chez Faya elle résiste elle est il
y a aussi des points de solidité est-ce
que vous diriez ça écoutez de moins en
moins pour l'instant elle résiste mais
on est un chouïa d'un basculement si la
droite réussit à faire passer
la clause de contournement de la Cour
suprême compte tenu du fait la Cour
suprême est le seul contre pouvoir
institutionnel en Israël contrairement
on se peut se passer aux États-Unis en
France en Grande-Bretagne mais c'est
fini je veux dire la en fait la cnsset
peut voter tous les lois qu'elle veut
son frein sans aucune obligation de
respecter le droit des minorités les
cours suprêmes c'est fait pour faire
respecter les droits fondamentaux des
gens s'il n'y a plus ça qu'est-ce qui
reste bon oui c'est une grande c'est une
grande faiblesse l'autre grande
faiblesse et le fait que les lois
fondamentales ça a été évoqué par Nissan
les lois fondamentales peuvent être
modifiées comme ça en espace de quelques
semaines à une majorité simple ce qu'est
quelque chose de totalement impensable
en France oui mais ça c'est le cas
depuis
le début de l'État d'Israël ça n'a pas
changé oui mais ce que j'essaie de
montrer dans mon livre c'est que depuis
le début il y a des faiblesses dans la
dém elle tenait à l'absence de
constitution à la faiblesse des lois
fondamentales au fait qu'il n'y a pas de
séparation entre religion et état en
Israël
le fait qu'il n'y a pas de droit
fondamental sur l'égalité
l'égalité ça n'existe pas entre moi
fondamental c'est vraiment absolument
insensé en juillet 2018 la droite a fait
passer la loi de l'État nation du peuple
juif kindelwa fondamentale les plus
importantes pas une fois le mode
démocratie n'est mentionné pas une fois
les mots l'égalité et d'émotionné si une
fois si une loi stigmaticante
stigmatisante et et il faut dire assez
assez humiliante pour les minorités pour
la minorités arabes pour la méthodologie
surtout les druses qui eux se sentent
très intégrés dans la société
israélienne
Mathieu un mot et ensuite
le contournement de la Cour Suprême ou
la remise en cause du pouvoir judiciaire
c'est précisément des éléments qu'on
retrouve dans le spectre des démocraties
il libérales en Europe quand on parle de
démocratie libérale en Europe en
pointant la Hongrie ici la Pologne
parfois c'est précisément ce type de
Data ou de contournement institutionnel
qu'on met en cause et est-ce que ça ça
voulait intervenir je pose ma dernière
démocratie fragile depuis la fondation
de l'État parce qu'on oublie très vite
que pendant les 21 premières années de
l'État
les Palestiniens donc des centaines de
milliers de personnes étaient placées
sous un régime militaire pendant les
premières vingt ans et puis en 60 et
c'est uniquement les Palestiniens et ça
on mentionne pas assez et depuis 67 il y
a l'occupation alors ça aussi ça
fragilise énormément la démocratie
israélienne et ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui
par exemple là il y a des manifestations
contre contre la réforme judiciaire et
c'est très intéressant d'observer ce qui
se passe parce que il y a bon il y a le
grand public c'est-à-dire ceux qui sont
contre en Netanya ou contre la réforme
de manière spécifique et disent il y a
un vrai risque pour la démocratie et il
y a ce que s'appelle ça vient tout juste
d'être fondé ça s'appelle le bloc contre
l'occupation qui dit écoutez avant de
parler des risques et avant de parler de
la démocratie démocratie qui est en
risque il faut tout d'abord parler de
l'occupation et ce qui a précédé à cette
réforme judiciaire parce que cette
réforme judiciaire je peux pas la
considérer comme surprenante elle ne
sort pas nulle part et d'ailleurs juste
de la juge béniche qui était donc la
présidente de la Cour suprême avait dit
le problème en Israël c'est que
l'occupation fonctionne comme un trou
noir qui aspire en fait la démocratie
israélienne et que donc c'est très
difficile d'être dans un système qui
vous avez un
une partie du territoire des lois
démocratiques et sur l'autre non et ça
pose aussi la question des alliés
d'Israël c'était l'un des éléments
d'actualité de cette journée de ce lundi
la visite du secrétaire d'État américain
Anthony blinken voilà il est possible
les mots qu'il a prononcé à son arrivée
en Israël il est de la responsabilité de
chacun de prendre des mesures pour
apaiser les tensions plutôt que de les
exacerber pour œuvrer à l'avènement d'un
jour où les citoyens n'auront plus peur
dans leur communauté leur foyer leur
lieu de culte c'est la seule façon
d'arrêter l'escalade de la violence qui
a pris trop de vie trop d'Israéliens
trop de Palestiniens
Sami Cohen dans l'histoire on sait que
les présidents américains ont souvent
joué un grand rôle pour tenter de de
d'obtenir une paix le plus souvent
malheureusement fragile entre israélien
et Palestiniens est-ce que c'est un
constat total d'un puissance qu'on fait
aujourd'hui vous dites ils ont tenté de
jouer un grand heureusement que vous
avez utilisé le mode tenté parce
qu'effectivement c'est un échec total du
début à la fin à l'époque Bill Clinton
avait fait tout son possible avec mais
tout son poids de la balance pour
rapprocher israélien palestinien il y
avait presque réussi ça n'a pas marché
mais ensuite
les autres présidents franchement n'ont
pas fait beaucoup d'efforts Obama il
faut dire n'a rien fait il n'a pas voulu
prendre de risques en se disant tant que
les parties ont présentes ne veulent pas
s'entendre moi je veux pas risquer
l'impopularité dans mon pays bon est
venu ensuite Trump dont on sait les
dégâts qu'il a causé en reconnaissant
Israël comme capitale du peuple
comme capitale d'Israël on reconnaissant
la juridiction israélienne sur le Golan
bon il n'a fait que convenait des choses
je crois que Biden est un peu sur cette
sur cette ligne il a un discours très je
suis pour les deux états il y a que ça
etc mais en fait il ne fait rien il ne
fait rien parce que je pense que tant
que les deux parties ne veulent pas
s'entendre il n'a que des coups à
prendre des deux côtés effectivement
peut-être ne fait-il rien parce qu'il a
vu que c'est prédécesseurs n'y ont pas
réussi non plus merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat ça
Mika et je rappelle le titre de votre
livre Israël une démocratie fragile
libre qui est donc publié aux éditions
Faya voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro de
sens public merci à toutes et à tous de
votre fidélité je vous dis à demain et
puis de noter le rendez-vous dans la
matinale et vous voyez son son visage
apparaître le secrétaire national du
Parti communiste Fabien Roussel sera
l'invité Dorian Mancini à 8 heures
demain matin belle soirée à à tous
[Musique]